suggestions for reducing a goiter naturally for someone who is a hyper thyroid as well as
reverse the hyperthyroidism not taking any medication for this condition. So hyperthyroid
is what's called Graves disease and that is an autoimmune condition. So you have antibodies that
have developed with autoimmune diseases when you develop antibodies. Your immune system makes
antibodies against your own tissue. And then you have destruction of that tissue and with Graves
disease or hyperthyroidism you have the rapid destruction of the tissue that spills out T3.
So normally your thyroid gland secretes thyroid hormone in the form of mainly T4. So you have T3
and T4. 95% of the thyroid hormone released by the thyroid gland is T4 that is not in the active
form. T3 is the active form. So it releases only about 5% in the active form. T4 is then converted
to T3 gradually over time throughout the day in the gut and in the liver so that you don't get this
spike. You need this nice balance of T3 hormone function in your body. So when a person notices
hyperthyroid symptoms they'll notice like kind of like it's crawling under their skin. They have
maybe increase in heart palpitations. They'll have that great idea but increase heart palpitations.
They'll feel you know just uneasy long-term issues with Graves disease are bulging eyes. Graves disease
can be very serious. So you want to make sure you get that checked. If someone called and they had
acute Graves disease symptoms they went and got checked and their T3 was elevated. I don't think you
should pull around with it. I think you should go get medication for it. If it's relatively under
control if you've had a history of Graves disease but it's now under control your labs are relatively
within normal limits. You can do things about it even if you're going to go get medication to
decrease thyroid function still you need to dig into one of the triggers that cause it. So with
every autoimmune disease you'll find triggers that stimulate more destruction of that organ. So with
the thyroid whether you have Hashimoto's which Hashimoto's can actually express as a hyperthyroid
at different times but it's typically expressed as a hypothyroid. Or if you have Graves disease or if
you have any other autoimmune disease meaning you have antibodies to other self-tissue you want to
make sure that you're finding out what your triggers are. So I go into triggers in detail on our
chronic disease and autoimmune course. I don't mean to push you to that however I probably have 50
videos in that course explaining these things. So it would be very helpful to spend 50 bucks and
join that course and start working your way through there to find those triggers because that can
greatly help a person with any autoimmune disease to calm things down. So the problem with an autoimmune
disease is you're getting self-destruction of that tissue which you have antibodies against.
And the common mistake that I see people make is that they're maybe going to a practitioner that
they're told that they might have Lyme disease or they're told that they have empty bar virus or
they're told that they have some sort of chronic infection and then they're treating that person
with antivirals, antibacterial, natural things and they think well you can't hurt anybody with
you know giving them garlic or giving them a kinesha or giving them something like that, a natural
anti-infective agent. But that's as far from the truth as you can get you could hurt somebody
quite badly. If you have antibodies to self-tissue, will this use Graves disease or Hashimoto's?
That's your thyroid gland as an example. If you have antibodies to your thyroid gland anything
you do that is going to stimulate an immune reaction is going to cause further destruction of
that which you have antibodies against your thyroid gland in this case. When your immune system is
stimulated you're going to kill that which you have antibodies against first. So that's the benefit
of having circulated antibodies against different diseases. If I have circulated antibodies you know
against certain virus and I'm exposed to that virus again in my immune system is stimulated because
because of that exposure I will kill that which I have antibodies against which will be that virus.
But if you have self-antibodies as well you will destroy that self-tissue. So when you have
self-antibodies, when you have a diagnosis of autoimmune disease and I'll tell you most people don't
know that they do. So they might just think that they have product disease. They might think that
well my problem is really that I have live disease or my problem is really that I have empty
bar or something like that. But because it showed up on the scanner because my practitioner tested
me for this and that showed up positive while you may have that. If you also have self-antibodies
and you're doing things that will stimulate an immune system in the idea that you're trying to kill
that pathogen you will be destroyed self-tissue. Really really important. I just got a blood test back
from somebody and they're showing antibodies to myelin cheese cells. That's neurological antibodies
to myelin cheese cells. Your myelin cheese cells are what cover your motor neurons and when you have
destruction of myelin cheese cells, I mean that is a debilitating disease. That's MS. So every time
that person stimulates an immune system to kill my disease per se, they've been going to different
practitioners to try to do that. They're actually causing more harm than good. They're destroying
self-tissue. They're progressing their autoimmune disease. In this case, you're causing a progression
of MS. I'm knowing because nobody ever ran the test. So you're going to run some tests to find out
what's going on. Many times when people have an autoimmune disease, again, like I said, they may be
treating the comorbidity of some other infection. They're taking immune stimulators. You also run the
risk of developing antibodies to other tissues. So over time, it's not uncommon that a person starts
with Graves disease or Hashimoto's disease, and now they have Lupus, or now they have Rubatyn arthritis,
or now they have antibodies to the rural tissue. So running the antibody tests can be extremely
beneficial to know what you need to try to protect. That's just getting a diagnosis. Then you want to
find run some different tests to get to find out what are your triggers. You can have triggers that
are environmental triggers, from chemicals and toxins and poisons in the environment. You can
have triggers from food sensitivities, so food antibodies. So like I said, you can't stimulate your
immune system. You have to be very careful not to stimulate your immune system if you have
self-antibodies, antibodies to self-tissue. But if you're eating something that you have antibodies
let's use glutinous as an example. So you have glianed antibodies to different glianed peptides.
And you're eating glutin on a daily basis. You find your immune response every time you eat that.
So you're going to have self-tissue destruction every time you eat glutin. That's a major issue.
So that's a trigger. So you might not even have stomach issues. It might not be at all. But you're
causing self-tissue destruction at that. Would you have antibodies against whether it be the thyroid
or the mild and cheese cells every time you eat that? So if you know you have antibodies to self-tissue,
a KAU know you have an autoimmune disease. You have to start digging in to find those triggers.
You could do different lab tests, different antibody tests against chemicals, different antibody
test against foods, antibody test against environmental things. So find out what those triggers are.
And you have to put out your Sherlock Holmes hat when I tell everybody it starts looking for
what I do this. It does make me feel worse. So that's how you would treat it. That's how you really
have to treat an autoimmune disease. There isn't like a secret supplement for treating an autoimmune
disease. You have to calm down the immune system. I guess the secret supplement for autoimmune
disease is to make sure you eat the wrong supplements. That's step one.